plus
et des tasses et
mais juste
Je recherche
anti
je te cherche
Et
Bien
Ici
rousses assis sur je cum
Eh bien, il s'est avéré que ma fille
après l'école, elle a commencé à s'attarder
a commencé à aller à la langue coréenne est venu
assez tard en hiver
il fait déjà noir et
toutes les heures il est déjà tard et puis
le temps de la viande était toutes les heures s'allume
8 heures sont venues et
pour moi c'est généralement un non-sens, je suis devenu elle
torturer qu'est-ce pourquoi si tard et
Je m'échauffe pour la messe, je reste, il s'avère que
sans nouveau prof parle de nous
après la messe, il rentre chez lui en voiture et
va me donner un ascenseur
J'en ai marre d'essayer un tel endroit pour la grippe
mon c'est le service je me suis si bien passé
gauche et le prêtre ne parlait que pour
c'est comme s'il n'y avait personne ici, dit-il
juste pour moi ici j'ai entendu les réponses à
mes questions et donc c'est comme ça que je suis après ça
fête des mages la première fois que nous sommes venus
me voilà 40 jours
jour après jour je suis comme ça
il fait froid la nuit en hiver ici c'est sur moi
le mien avait l'air fou en hiver
c'est froid, c'est boueux, et bien, plus
le temps est comme ça
il n'y a pas un tel gel, mais c'est de la neige fondante
toute la saleté et et tu y vas elle moi
parfois mon mari me regarde comme ça
appelle déjà une religieuse, eh bien, je ne serai pas offensé
maintenant il y a des moments comme ça, toi aussi
quand ces gouttes viennent ici
parfois c'est vraiment comme ça
comme si j'étais seul et qu'il n'y avait personne pour moi
tout ceci est un sermon tout tout tout
toutes les réponses ici j'obtiens la réponse c'est sur
vos questions
un ou
en liberté
Mais
Et
il y a 15 ans
support pour la cheminée dans le sac puis sur
ordures jeter 7 envie ou problèmes de réseau
et j'ai collé la boucle tom allongé sur les détails
rendre compte à tous les collègues
défaut tequila kherson depp enchères
enduro 2 porte de jésus
respect de la société pour les croyants
la population locale a été amenée à u-2
à la fin du régime, bien, et le litige d'un lion léger
et envelopper
sur le réseau social main tenir le champ désirable
kenzie bam nous élève des enfants nous construisons
nous n'avons rien à partager la vie au contraire si nous
nous vivons ensemble avec analyseur de charbon plus tôt
ou signer et il est donc très important
Je souligne que le nom est casey adams one in
vendant un et lionness focus se faire virer ou
même dans n'importe quel pays
pratique pour z en 2z où il a vécu la question quand
µm et
et ici les russes sont moyens
quatrième génération est ou petite famille
et je suis et elle ne figure pas sur 5 sièges
Et
UN
la renaissance plaît à ilya au cas où votre
problèmes devant les ordures du canapé et non le long et
stocks de forfaits de ski à l'étranger au service de celui-ci
mode biscuit joué dans le paragraphe
seulement si vous croyez et ici et avez mangé ou
livres sbt ici il y a beaucoup de personnes âgées dans
marche d'âge moyen juste de la manière habituelle
visuellement
et passer je ne juge pas venir mec il
Rabel vit un peu, les lièvres sont faciles
nouveauté cherche la f notre futur peuple
eh bien un peu de conseils fils canard là-bas les gens
s'intègre dans
infu musulman surnaturel et
le mensonge ne donne pas aux murs un goût de ramzil important
dans ce que nous avons laissé à son mari
va progressivement dans ce sens il y a un tel
ce sont pas mal des diables mais étant donné
vêtements de modèle ton sur ton avec précision dans le nom
Pas
sur ses points voici injavino
ou même le développer va submerger
sentir si
et nous sur je prends même madone
il multiplie l'égal de la saint valentin
Mais
mais non
en général, j'étais si ronde
peint à la maison je suis venu à l'église
j'ai eu les cheveux blancs coupés comme ça
peint à partir de là
tu as besoin d'écharpes et de jupes
et je suis venu comme une chemise rouge en noir
si luxuriante en général souvent en général alors
église là-bas le long de celle-ci mais à ce moment-là je
d'une manière ou d'une autre, je suis juste allé voir le prêtre le
m'a regardé comme ça
va crier
travailler à partir d'ici j'ai eu peur
effrayé
et ma grand-mère a couru vers moi comme ça
couvert de cette robe alors allons-y allons-y et
baptême lui-même, je pensais qu'il me noierait comme
comme s'il avait quelque chose comme ça
moi pour avant les mots et c'est tout ce que je suis
c'était fait comme ça donc c'est moi
donc tout s'est passé en général
bien sûr, je ne le sais pas, et je ne le sais pas du tout
Je sais comment tout s'est passé et tout ça
donc
Je ne me sens pas mal après ça
alors j'ai quitté l'église je n'avais pas moi
plus tard, lorsque
probablement deux ans se sont écoulés, je suis déjà là
Je suis déjà allé
les gens pour qu'ils me créent comme il se doit
moi le rite ici et puis j'ai déjà je suis déjà allé à
à la maison, je ne sais pas si je te le trouverais ou pas
ce serait probablement beaucoup plus long mais c'est tout
tu n'es pas en vain tous les accidents ne le sont pas
se passe dans le monde tout signifie qu'il devrait en être ainsi
donc je dois être ici parce que
c'est là que je suis venu
baptisé
baptême lui-même
la peine n'était pas lui-même
Ce
je veux des légions
pizza
ils sont couverts pour elle
loisirs de parking
satellites battle.net
temps
papa final
Oui
et qui rachètent les deux
ou
Mais
UN
Et
vous connaissez le Kirghizistan jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
il y a une telle rivalité
pas toutes mes icônes de cheveux momentanées
le joindre Kirghizistan 100 secondes
sur venturi célèbre pour sa classe unique
n'est-ce pas
et l'esquif a demandé à don gon kiddy kiddy seulement
modèle Faina n'a pas sifflé et bien bien bien vôtre
matsuko n'a pas hésité et en panty buffet
et appelez à dc
la situation est tellement dramatique en général en général je
Je ne dirai pas qu'on verra déjà le tout
abandonné le conducteur atteindra un peu plus
une sorte d'hostilité et ainsi de suite
ainsi de suite, je ne suis toujours pas pour aujourd'hui
observer toutes les vacances que nous accueillons
l'un l'autre
lil 10 fusionnons bien, ma fine ligne droite n'était pas
part de boutons
d'un pas très étouffant je voudrais vinyusha
mods dans le jardin attendu dans 1 5 chansons
Orthodoxie à Moscou
UN
iphone
le principe du don n'interfère pas dans notre
nous n'intervenons pas de la même manière
politiser jusqu'à ce qu'il soit interrompu par Goldwin
l'été ou
lethal 80 sur le ton pour tout
nous avions très peu de souveraineté
nombre de mosquées et notre logiciel pour la politique
tout prier si les madrasas étaient
unités il y a aujourd'hui méga si
plus de 100 si les aisselles se développent déjà
nous verrons les soins de marque Khaidu minsk alors
faut faire un pélerinage maintenant
ce numéro tous ses démons politiques volent
Discutons qu'il est un lâche a donné olya faire
le professeur est déjà à la porte, mais l'eau est misérable
salon pour les bars et assis médité à la poubelle
fait un pèlerinage au pays commun je
dit que le chef ne travaille pas. tous face à
magicien râteau ki aussi 1 professeur
Selon nos données, nous considérons environ 80% de l'ADN
mais cette camarade de poney ivre n'est pas elle-même pas
alors pour lui ce sont des adhérents
christianisme thompson pour la cigarette du dimanche
blessé dénoncé à quel point nous voulons de la
chiens
du marché intel samsung julienne des jeunes arbres
que nous en avions quatre au total pour
le seul dont nous avons besoin de 8 poulets et
tournée de conneries musicales demandez ici qu'ils prennent
poste vacant
vélo pour les confessions de lion je ne me vois pas
maintenant je ne vais nulle part, je vais surtout pour ça
ce que nous avons ici, eh bien, c'est combien
les enfants avaient l'habitude de se rassembler le soir sur
plume toute moue
raconte toutes sortes de choses différentes
des histoires et surtout des enfants racontent
sur les miracles d'Allah
nos enfants racontent les heures de jésus
Christ et maintenant ils ont ça maintenant souvent déjà
tout le monde n'a pas grandi